♪ Nilay's Chemistry ♪
- Let's start off with a problem.
A person drops a pound of bricks
and a pound of feathers
down from their window,
which has more matter?
The bricks or the feathers?
Now, you might be tempted to say feathers
but let's recall what matter is.
Matter is anything that
occupies space and has mass.
Mass defines the quantity
of matter in an object.
Mass tells us when we have a
lot of matter like an elephant
or only a little bit
of matter like a mouse.
So back to the problem,
which has more matter?
A pound of bricks or a pound of feathers?
Well, they both have a mass of one pound
so they have the same amount of matter.
Now, even though bricks and
feathers are very different,
they're both made up of matter.
But what exactly is matter made up of?
Matter is made up of one
or many microscopic building
blocks called atoms.
An atom is the smallest unit of matter
and they are so tiny
that a penny contains
approximately 2.3 times 10
to the 22nd atoms, or 23 sextillion atoms.
However, all of the sextillions
of atoms in a penny aren't the same.
A penny is made up of
copper and zinc atoms.
Copper and zinc are just two examples
of the 118 different elements that exist.
An element is a substance
that cannot be decomposed
into a simpler substance
by chemical means.
Essentially, if you have an element,
no reaction with heat or another
chemical can break it down
into a simpler substance.
Hydrogen, oxygen, carbon, gold,
and arsenic are all different elements.
When you have a sample of an element,
it can consist of one or more atoms.
So, elemental neon exists
as a singular, free atom,
which does not interact
with any other atoms.
Elemental gold usually exists as millions
or trillions of connected
atoms while oxygen exists
in a diatomic molecular
form with two oxygen atoms.
Oxygen in its elemental form
is an example of a molecule
because its two atoms are
chemically bound together.
A molecule is the smallest physical unit
of an element or compound, and
it is anything made up of two
or more atoms held together
by a chemical bond.
So if atoms are held together by bonds
then it also makes sense that
these bonds can be broken
and allow different atoms
to then bond together.
Almost like Lego blocks,
for example, water
or H2O comprises two hydrogen
atoms and one oxygen atom.
In this chemical reaction, hydrogen or H2
and oxygen or O2 react to form water.
The chemical bonds holding
the diatomic oxygen
molecules together are broken
so that each oxygen atom can then bond
with two hydrogen atoms.
By rearranging the way
that atoms are attached to one another.
Reactions like this can
occur where one molecule
is transformed into another.
A good analogy is that
atoms are like letters
and molecules are like words.
If we change the order or type of letter,
we make different words
with different meanings.
If we change the order or type of atom,
we make different molecules
with different properties.
So let's summarize what we have learned.
Matter is made up of atoms
and we can obtain different types
of matter from objects being
built with different elements.
So while a pound of bricks
and a pound of feathers
have the same amount
of matter, they're made
of different elemental
building blocks called atoms
that then give them different properties.
This is why a pound of
bricks dropping down
from above is a lot scarier
than a pound of feathers.
♪ Nilay's Chemistry Videos ♪